cette journée s'est globalement bien
déroulé dans les transports en commun
mais il faut le dire il y avait très peu
de voyageurs aujourd'hui dans le métro
la ratp estime une fréquentation à
hauteur de 15 à 20% du trafic habituel
il faut préciser que 60 stations de
métro restent fermés sur les 302 du
réseau francilien
mais du côté des voyageurs il s'agissait
d'une journée plutôt habituel ça va ça
s'est très bien passé tout le monde
respecter les règles de sécurité
et ça valait enfin pas trop
d'encombrement donc ça va tout le monde
a son masque quoi ça va dans l'intérêt
de la santé de sa vie ça n'a rien de
libyen position quelconque c'est c'est
dans l'intérêt de chacun de nous de la
survie alain avait personne et on n'a
rien d'un peu de monde donc non non non
tout le monde avait respecté un incident
tout de même à signaler ce matin sur la
ligne 13 une ligne très fréquentée par
les parisiens un problème technique due
aux intempéries d'hier soir a causé des
retards
conséquence des rames bondées de
voyageurs rendant impossible la
distanciation d'un mètre entre chaque
passager du côté des trains la
fréquentation était elle aussi assez
faible à titre d'exemple un trafic
comparables à la journée du 5 décembre
dernier une journée de grève selon
l'estimation de l'association d'usagers
plus de trains mais là encore cette
faible densité de voyageurs est dû au
nombre de trains en circulation
seuls 55 % des lignes sont ouvertes et
la sncf estime un retour à la normale à
la fin du mois de mai je rappelle que le
port du masque est obligatoire dans les
transports en commun pour les voyageurs
aux heures de pointe
une attestation d'employeur est
nécessaire c'est à dire entre 6h30 et
9h30 et l'après midi entre 16 heures et
19 heures les passagers ayant un motif
impérieux peuvent eux aussi se déplacer
en transports en commun
mais attention à partir de mercredi les
justificatifs et le port du masque
feront l'objet de contrôles sans masque
ou sans attestation les voyageurs
s'expose à une amende de 135 euros